good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp
1688
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
scp-1688's native habitat designated
site 1688 has been declared a national
wildlife reserve and is permanently
closed to civilian traffic foundation
personnel in conjunction with the united
states forest service are to patrol the
perimeter of site 1688 to discourage
unauthorized access no personnel are to
enter site 1688 itself unless scp-1688
is not present at the time in the event
it becomes necessary to enter site 1688
while scp-1688 is present or to enter
any other area scp-1688 is occupying
personnel are to wear grounded insulated
full-body suits at all times
the foundation is to monitor
meteorological conditions in the area of
scp-1688 at all times for any indication
of events favorable to movement in the
event that scp-1680 leaves site 1688 it
is to be tracked in real time and any
populated areas within its path are to
be issued mandatory evacuation orders
under the pretense of tornadoes or
severe flooding meteorological data
distributed in the media is to be
censored to remove any information
regarding
scp-1688's existence
any persons surviving an encounter with
scp-1688
are to be debriefed and administered
class a or b amnestics as appropriate
all examples of scp-1688-1
encountered shall be seized for study
and archival
description
scp-1688 is an electrical storm which
under normal circumstances remains
stationary over an area of square
kilometers in the u.s state of
the geological features of the region
along with local wind and atmospheric
patterns contribute to a state that
encourages the permanent formation of
storm clouds and subsequent electrical
discharge monitoring stations installed
during periods of inactivity indicate
that cloud-to-surface lightning strikes
within scp-1688
occur approximately 280 to 300 times per
hour cloud-to-cloud lightning has been
observed to occur as often as 3000 times
per hour these lightning strikes have
been found to occur in regular patterns
analysis of these patterns and of
electrical activity within the storm
clouds themselves has presented evidence
of rhythmic oscillations similar to
electrical activity in the human brain
whenever meteorological conditions in
the regions near scp-1688 are conducive
to the formation of thunderstorms
scp-1688 will migrate from its principal
habitat in the direction of prevailing
winds no means of preventing scp-1688
from moving out of its habitat has been
discovered while moving
scp-1688 will deliberately move towards
areas populated by humans when multiple
populated areas are within its range it
will continue to move in the direction
of the largest one
scp-1688 will continue to follow the
winds moving in the direction of any
populated regions along its route until
environmental conditions cause it to
dissipate upon so doing
scp-1688 will form again in its original
habitat within 24 hours
whether it is moving or in its native
habitat cloud to surface lightning
emanating from scp-1688
will deliberately target any human
beings within its range regardless of
the presence of any targets more
suitable for lightning strikes
scp-1688 will additionally target any
inanimate objects that will conduct an
electrical shock into a human in cases
where scp-1688 has entered populated
areas this phenomenon has extended to
targeting automobiles in motion and
striking exposed metal on residences
leading to persons inside being
electrocuted by electronic devices or
kitchen fixtures mortality rates among
persons struck by lightning emanating
from scp-1688
are slightly less than those of persons
struck by ordinary lightning
any persons surviving being struck by
scp-1688 will upon their recovery feel a
strong compulsion to begin constructing
complex machinery out of any electrical
or mechanical parts they can acquire
samples of this machinery designated
scp-1688-1
acquired to date have included a large
assortment of devices of largely unknown
purpose composed of pieces salvaged from
home computers and electronics fixtures
automobiles simple mechanical devices
and several pieces fashioned by the
makers by melting down and sculpting
metals and plastics affectees engaged in
the construction of scp-1688-1
will engage in this activity in all
times when not sleeping or attending to
physical needs we'll spend all funds at
their disposal on acquiring equipment to
build with and will collaborate on other
affected individuals in combining pieces
to make larger machines affected
individuals will attempt to incorporate
any electronic or mechanical equipment
at their disposal into scp-1688-1
affected individuals otherwise remain in
full possession of their mental
faculties and in interviews have been
unable to explain how or why they are
engaged in this behavior the ultimate
purpose of scp-1688-1 is unknown
scp-1688-1 objects of highly similar
appearance to each other have been found
in the wake of several containment
breaches it is currently speculated
based on the volume of material created
by effectes and the recurrence of
particular fragments that the completed
machine would weigh in excess of
kilograms
scp-1688 came to the foundation's
attention in 19
when an unusually high instance of
lightning-related injuries
was followed by reports of mass hysteria
and several arrests of persons stealing
electronic equipment for the purpose of
incorporating it into scp-1688-1
a subsequent survey of local folklore
discovered rumors of anomalous lightning
phenomena dating to the first arrival of
europeans in the
century as well as native american
legends of a thunder god predating
european contact this is interview log
1688 1
interview log 1688 1
interviewed scp-1688
interviewer dr
forward following an encroachment by
scp-1688 into
on
20
an
scp-1688-1 device was found including a
lightning rod several large batteries a
pair of stereo speakers a microphone and
an electronic voice synthesizer dr
speculated that the device had been
designed for the purpose of facilitating
communication between the foundation and
scp-1688
and ordered it to be installed within
site 1688 during the next period when
scp-1688 left the area a microphone
camera and speakers were installed on
site as well upon the next formation of
scp-1688 within site 1688 lightning
struck the installed rod on the device
following which the device began to
produce a voice which held the following
conversation
begin log
test
test business work functional
we are receiving you
my name is doctor
and i am a representative of the scp
foundation
what is the name of the being i am
addressing
are you a builder
i i don't understand your question
are you as those that built for me
i am of the same species as the person
who constructed the device you're
communicating through if that is your
question
send more builders
i can't do that right now my job is to
learn about you
what is your name
i am unconcerned with your questions
send more builders
why
i need to teach more builders they must
build the work is incomplete
are you aware that many of the people
you come into contact with have died as
a result
none willing to build shall die
i see
what is this work you refer to
are you in prison
i am lost send more builders
okay i think this concludes today's
lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you were all dismissed goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
anvil
aletraon
derivative
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
tailored printers
clad the lad perpetually confused meat
tech pilot
zignar
your local foundation agent
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
sayo dio damnares
eric corbige
longinus
the morrigan
karim el ashmuy
james sabha and nj bojack
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you